und jetzt zu einem fall der uns alle
tief erschüttert und für den es
eigentlich überhaupt gar keine worte
gibt das bka fahndet nach einem
kinderschänder der mindestens sieben
kleine jungen schwer missbraucht hat
sein jüngstes opfer ist gerade einmal
ein jahr alt die vergewaltigung hat der
täter gefilmt und ins internet gestellt
und über die jagd nach diesen
kinderschänder sprechen wir gleich mit
sebastian zwiebel von cybercrime center
der generalstaatsanwaltschaft frankfurt
zuvor fassen wir aber noch einmal die
wichtigsten hinweise zusammen
der man filmt die fürchterlichen taten
veröffentlicht die aufnahmen im darknet
die bka ermittler befürchten dass er
sich auch heute noch an kindern vergeht
bittet nun die öffentlichkeit um hilfe
und zeigen die tatorte seine
schrecklichen treibens wer kennt diese
badezimmer einmal ein grünes wannenbad
einmal ein badezimmer mit diesem roten
badezimmer läuft auch dieser flur mit
dem auffälligen roten koffer spielt eine
rolle der täter dürfte zwischen 31 und
51 jahre alt sein besonders widerlich er
hat vermutlich beruflich oder
ehrenamtlich mit kindern zu tun auf den
zwischen 2015 und 2019 dienstag nicht
gestellten aufnahmen verwendet er
außerdem oft das wort hai als begrüßung
das bka veröffentlicht außerdem
gegenstände die auf den missbrauchs
bildern zu sehen sind wer erkennt diese
unterhose mit der aufschrift 932 bronx
oder diese gestreiften socken außerdem
trug eines der kinder diese pflaster in
deutschland fahren die seien nach der em
20 16 das bka möchte wissen erkennen sie
diese kinder taschenlampe verwendet im
märz 2009 10 oder diese windel größe 4
falls sie sich erinnern bitte melden sie
sich beim bundeskriminalamt unter 06 11
55 18 44
[Musik]
und uns jetzt zugeschaltet ist sebastian
zwiebel von cybercrime center der
generalstaatsanwaltschaft frankfurt
guten abend herr zwiebel und vielen dank
dass ihr zeit für uns haben
lassen sie uns zeit einsteigen und am
fall vielleicht können sie uns einmal
sagen wie sind sie denn auf diesen täter
gekommen und vor allem wie lange
ermitteln die kollegen schon
naja dementiert da sind wir ja noch
nicht insofern gekommen als wir wissen
um wen es sich dabei handelt wir sind
auf die person also auf seine funktion
im dark knight gekommen weil wir
ermittlungen gegen eine andere person
hatten und haben ihn als chatpartner
identifiziert das war im jahr 2018 als
wir ursprünglich gegen andere personen
ermittelt haben und im jahr 2009 10
haben sich die ermittlungen auf diese
person konzentriert ohne dass wir wissen
oder wussten um wen es sich dabei
handelt dann haben wir relativ lange
versucht seine identität zu klären das
ist uns nicht gelungen und im jahr 2020
sind die ermittlungen wieder ins rollen
gekommen nachdem wir die kamera
identifiziert identifiziert haben mit
dem er womöglich einige bilder gemacht
hat und seitdem sind die ermittlungen
wieder intensiviert worden hat er denn
all diese videos mit einem account namen
hochgeladen und handelt sich dabei um
eine tauschbörse oder was genau ist das
5 forum
ja da kann ich natürlich nicht zu sehr
ins detail gehen um keine anleitung zu
geben aber in der tat handelt es sich um
auf jeden fall ein bekanntes forum in
dem er jede von uns identifiziert wurde
als chatpartner wie gesagt der person
die zunächst ins visier geraten wurde
die auch identifiziert ist die aber sich
über seine chatpartner nicht einlässt
also keine weiteren angaben macht so
dass wir jetzt auf die bevölkerung
angewiesen sind uns bei der
identifizierung des aktuellen
beschuldigten zu helfen wie lange sind
denn diese video sequenzen sind das ein
paar sekunden oder handelt es sich hier
um mehrere stunden gefilmten missbrauch
also seien sie sicher sind
minuten und insgesamt stunden
unerträglich materials
die unsere ermittler anschauen mussten
umso mehr erfreut werden wir wenn unsere
ermittlungen zum erfolg führen und wir
den die täter infizieren können sie
haben es ja gesagt die kamera das ist
also eine wichtige spur ein wichtiges
indiz dafür die spuren nach berlin
steglitz was können sie dazu sagen
ja wir wissen dass die kamera in berlin
steglitz erworben wurde der mutmaßliche
täter hat sie bar bezahlt gab also keine
möglichkeit über eine mögliche
kreditkartenzahlung auf die identität zu
kommen mehr wissen wir allerdings nicht
es ist natürlich nicht sicher dass der
täter auch aus berlin stammt das
theoretisch ist natürlich möglich dass
er über ein wochenende in berlin war
oder vielleicht sogar absichtlich einen
gegenstand in berlin gekauft hat um eine
falsche fährte zu legen das ist teil
unserer ermittlungen gerade aber auf
jeden fall ist es ein indiz dass wir
sicher sind dass sie dort in berlin
gekauft wurde wie bei vielen vielen dank
für dieses gespräch und vor allem
drücken wir ihnen und den kollegen
natürlich die daumen dass du diesen mann
schnell schnappen dankeschön erinnern ja
und wir fassen für sie noch einmal
zusammen denn der täter der wird auf 31
bis 51 jahre geschätzt und vermutlich
hat er eben beruflich oder ehrenamtlich
mit kindern zu tun wenn sie jetzt
hinweise auf diesen kinderschänder haben
dann wenden sie sich unbedingt an das
bka unter der nummer 0 6 11 55 18 44